trying to get that daddy beard y'all
there that easier today we are trying
lush beauty products I'm actually really
irresponsible and don't have much of any
like beauty routine the morning I like
to wash my face with the face wash and
then I will use a SPF 15 lotion I
actually use one lush product that's
called Kalamazoo it's a facial scrub
situation but it's good for your beer
you don't I'm saying so if you want your
beer looking at your own sand on the
leek you usually you should get that
pangalactic
gargle blaster mouthwash tabs this stuff
smelling is supposed to be in your mouth
nibble the tab in swish no other
pollinators
it says nibble oh god you didn't nimble
hmm hmm oh boy was that yellow mine
didn't taste that bad initially it was
like a little chalky so I wasn't ready
for that that texture I would take this
and pop it like before a date think
about it
[Music]
you see at the bottom this was made by
Chelsea whoa it tells you who did it rub
your lips soft never heard that sentence
before my life what his lips gonna be
nice and exfoliated after it's over I
feel like if I have a sip of like
lemonade right now it's gonna burn they
feel like I just put lip gloss on it
feels softer and sweeter my lips feel
[ __ ] fantastic mine smells just like
cold brew coffee
this wasn't massage my face for 15
minutes who is time oh it feels so good
very gooey so we went to the bathroom
and washed off the bits from our face it
feels smooth actually you got to try
both and I definitely really like the
green one
you're like woke my face up because it
was like minty fresh I will say I didn't
like it I felt my face feels very dry
right now but you know our like our skin
is just different because I feel like it
takes almost too much oil out of my
particular snare does and I'm more than
happy to put it back in
yeah I really like these life products I
think my favorite was the the lip candy
sugar stuff you're doing a lot of stuff
you gotta chew up your own mouthwash
you gotta scrub your lips I really love
that the products are fresh like that is
the one thing I could say like
everything tasted smelled fresh so lush
get yourself
[Music]
[Music]